she adored it i mean i remember once  when i was up at  balmoral with her zara was  competing in the olympic games and  looked like she was going to win a medal  and and i thought that we'd be flying  down to greenwich  to watch to watch her get on but the  queen said to me  i just can't i'm just so nervous  i can't face up to it let's go out for a  picnic so we drove up onto the one of  the mountain sides and  one of the cabins and we had a little  private picnic just the two of us  and and eventually the queen said to me  i can't stand it any longer  can you radio your backups and find out  how zara got on so i radioed them found  out she'd won the silver medal  and i remember the queen just grabbed me  and we were dancing around in circles on  this hill in scotland and that's a  memory that will stay with me forever  more